I used to listen to people asking for
help that's what I was trying to do is
help people but I was falling myself
darkness only responds to darkness
[Music]
I'm daredevil I have made many mistakes
but I accept the debt
I beg because of better
Prison has changed me what is it you're
saying I want to make a deal
he's claiming to have change but they
don't know him like I do
the last time that we spoke you
threatened to me that is something that
I cannot forgive not stopping for good
this time it's only one way to stop me
but you're gonna do it you sure about
that
just be careful that you don't become
the monster
because I've tried to make this city a
better place
to tell the world who you really are
someone who's now showing his true
colors
sometimes you have to help on precious
it's a greater good
he needs a new villain
I think I might have found him daredevil
is our true public enemy
the brutal attack has been carried out
by nut
daredevil
who are you I'm daredevil
you
you